there have been clashes outside a south
african high school where people are
protesting against racism
the demonstrators accuse the
establishment of its discriminating
against black students
now tear gas was used outside the cape
town school which allegedly held a
graduation event
where only white pupils and teachers
attended the school denies this and says
the function was private for me de
miller has more
from near the school in cape town
a number of eff members about 2 000 of
them in fact
tried to move closer to the school
you'll see behind me they're now behind
a police barricade but to keep them back
police once again
fire tear gas and stun grenades have
also used water cannon
to prevent these protesters from
approaching
the school they say only 500 protesters
are or would be allowed through and
that's why as we see
this is why we see this police barricade
and this heavy police presence
protesters here have in fact been quite
peaceful
and they've also accused police of being
heavy-handed
they're also apart from targeting the
school they're also angry with police
saying that they're racist and they
wouldn't respond
in the same manner to white protesters
or
if marches were white it wouldn't be the
same scenario so people here are angry
and ultimately the target is bracken
file high school which
they accuse of racism this goes back
to a function that was held a year-end
function for final year students
once the official dance and interview
function was cancelled by the school
because of covert 19 restrictions it
appears
as if students had their own private
function this is what the school is
saying
but there are black students at the
school who say they've been
discriminated against and none of them
were invited
to this function they weren't allowed to
attend
we've also heard a number of former and
prison students say that this goes back
years and this is a school where there's
been a lack
of integration a lack of black teachers
and there's a greater problem of racism
at the school the school
has denied that but has also admitted
that some work has to be done in that
they're now listening
to how black students feel well let's
speak to deva mavinger he's the southern
africa director at human rights watch
joins me now via skype from london good
to have you with us
on the program sir i mean sometimes we
can view a situation and think it's been
blown out of all proportion
from your understanding of what's
happened at this particular school what
conclusion are you drawing
well what is clear is that there was an
incident in which
black students were excluded from a
graduation ceremony
and what needs to happen is for the
south african authorities
to lead into an independent
investigation
into exactly what happened there is need
for sensitivity in dealing with race
issues
so the authorities must establish what
happened
and ensure that they are no incidents of
racism that are tolerated
particularly given uh sorry
when we talk of south africa it's and
its long history of racial injustice
it's obviously a very sensitive subject
as you said and and
that we thought that might have been
resolved
after the end of apartheid but the issue
of race and racial injustice
continues to simmer why
well partly because south africa remains
a deeply divided society and
some of the race issues have not been
resolved what happened was that
minority white rule ended in 1994
but the healing process is far from
being
being complete so there is need for the
authorities to continue to do more
and also in schools or private spaces in
the public
there is need for more action to ensure
integration
and healing so that we address this
deep-seated
divisions address divisions and also
elements of xenophobia that have not
been resolved to this day
and you know acts of continued
segregation should not be tolerated
it is it is bizarre in the fact that
this the rainbow nation has not been
able to reconcile
white and black communities considering
the anc which is a majority black
political party has actually been in
charge
of government for nyon baron you know
three decades do you think they would
have sorted this
by now
well certainly much more remains to be
done and
the great work that was done by the
truth and reconciliation commission
at the end of apartheid in 1994
was perhaps it did not go far enough in
ensuring accountability there was truth
telling
but perhaps not so much about
accountability and
ensuring that the divisions the
inequalities
are resolved once and for all so there
is need for the anc
and other political parties in south
africa to take race issues very
seriously
and the steps that require to be taken
to
you south africa and make it truly a
rainbow nation and not just
at the level of rhetoric
there are obviously deep-seated problems
if i just bring in one particular case
that happened in 2016 a white man called
brandon huntley
was granted asylum in canada based on an
argument
uh that whites were disproportionately
affected by crime in south africa sort
of slightly based on
on the race issue that ignited debate
around equality and fairness
and that all south africans were
affected by crime discrimination or
injustice so
sort of with white black and indian
communities feeling aggrieved at any
point in time
one wonders how this is ever going to
get solved
well the south african authorities
should prioritize race issues and
addressing that
and ensuring that there is no one who is
left behind or that they do not
uh completely ignore you know the rights
of
minority groups including the white
minority
now that there is a black majority
government but
it it means there is a lot of work not
just for the government but for the
communities themselves
and also a need not to
go back to the times of segregation uh
to the times of
apartheid where racism was legalized
there is need
to focus on building
a truly rainbow nation that south africa
can behave we'll see what does happen
it's always uh good to get your input to
deva mavinger from human rights watch
thanks for joining us from london so
thank you thank you